Merhaba Hoş geldiniz
Seyran Solakoğlu ufak bir tanıtım
yaptılar
bugün buraya geliş sebebim daha çok
gençler için esasında Yani neden bir
eğitimli Yurt dışında eğitim görmüş bu
kadar lissan bilen bu kadar ilim okumuş
insan Çiftçi olur Ben ne olmalıyım
sorusuna belki birazcık ilham
olabileceğini umut ediyorum
Öncelikle Evet İsviçre'de İlkokul 5 lise
son orada Ondan sonra Amerika'ya gittim
İktisat okudum Davranış Bilimleri okudum
ondan sonra Türkiye'ye geldim çiftçilik
yaptım şimdi
Bence okurken bir insanın tam olarak ne
olacağını bilmesi çok istisnaidir
Dolayısıyla Herkes her zaman ne
yapacağını bilmiyor olabilir ne
olacağını bilmiyor olabilir ve gençlerin
hakkında Acaba ben Ne olsam ne okusam
nasıl bir yere doğru gitsem nasıl Bir
Karıya peşinde koşsan gibilerinden deli
deli sorular olacaktır inanın benim
kariyer planlamanın hiçbir tarafında
çiftçilik yoktu Yani bazen insanlar
Hayat alıyor belli bir yerlere getiriyor
ama buradaki sorulması gereken en önemli
şey şu; bir Ben nasıl bir hayat yaşamak
istiyorum Yani dünyayı mı değiştirmek
istiyorum
param bir yaratmak istiyorum rutinimi
yaşamak istiyorum alışılagelmiş bir
düzen içinde mi yaşamak istiyorum yoksa
Hayır ben bir şeyleri değiştirebilirim
gibi böyle bir idarenin var mı bu çok
önemli Ondan sonra ikinci bakılacak en
önemli bir konu
Ben hangi alanda birazcık fark
yaratabilirim Çünkü bir insanın
okuduğunu anlayabilmesi
anladığı ile ilgili kendine ve
karşısındaki bilgiyi veren kişiye
eleştirel düşünüp doğru bir şekilde
kendine hitap ederek doğru soruları
sorması eleştirel düşünebilmesi bunu da
matematikle birleştirdiğiniz zaman bir
insanın yapamayacağı hiçbir şey yok
çünkü bir de bir yapıyorsa Onların da
İhtiyacı var
Sonuç olarak aldıkları eğitimle ve bu
yetenekleriyle bunu yapacaklardır
Dolayısıyla bu yetenekleri geliştirmek
çok önemli ki bunun ispata benim benim
aldığım eğitimde bugün icra ettiğim
mesleği hakikaten ilk bakışta baktığımız
zaman çok bağlantılı bir tarafı yok
çiftçiliği seçtim çünkü
Endişelerim vardı yaşadığımız ülke 5
yılda bir 7 yılda bir krize giriyor bu
krize girdiği zaman muhakkak her krizde
belli sektörlere etkileniyor ya ben
nasıl bir işe girersem hayatını idame
ederim bir fark yaratabilirim diye
baktım da en verimsiz ne var diye baktım
ve benim çevremde en önemli
hepimizi gıdası hepimizi buzdolabından
bahsediyoruz ve en ilkel kalmış sektörü
tanımı olduğunu gördüm ve ben aslında
birazcık bu bilinçle buluşuyor işine
geliyor
hepimize yemek yiyoruz gıda yiyoruz
dünyanın en önemli konusu şu anda iklim
değişikliği dünyadaki iklim
değişikliğine sebep veren en
yoğun eleştiri alan sektörlerden bir
tanesi tarım ve hayvancılık
işte olaya Biraz buradan görmek
gerekiyor öbür taraftan her gün 3 milyar
insan karnı aç bir şekilde yatağa
giriyor
Ama öbür taraftan da bir şişmanlık
obezite problemi var bir dengesizlik var
yani gıdanın dağılımı ile ilgili
Bu da yine çift kişilikle alakalı bir
konu kaynakların israfı söz konusu yine
çiftçilikle ilgili bir konu Yani Babadan
kalma sistem işte 50 kilo bilmem ne
gübresi atıyorsun Ondan sonra da işte
aradan bir ay geçince bilmem ne gübresi
atıyorsun oluyor işte sana bitki olmuyor
ve attığı gübrenin hem toprağa hem içme
suyu yok
zehirlediğinin farkında olmadığı gibi
cebini de zehirliyor Çünkü israf ediyor
Şimdi size bu dünyadan biraz da benim
dünyama doğru çekmek istiyorum
toprak altında giden
fiila giden sensörler sayesinde her
santimetre kare toprağın
mutfak kapasitesi olduğunu matematik
formülüyle bulabiliyorum Dolayısıyla ben
mesela 100 litre bagajı olan bir arabaya
200 litre hacimlik bir ürün koymak
istediğiniz zaman su mesela
kalan yüz Muhtemelen taşıt gidecektir
Ben benim toprağımın bagajının ne burcu
olduğunu biliyorum ve ölçebiliyorum
Dolayısıyla herkesin kullandığından daha
az
herkesten daha ucuza ve bitkinin de
ihtiyacını bildiğim için onu nereden
biliyorum ben bitkilerle konuşabiliyorum
nasıl matematikle konuşuyorum matematik
tabiatın Aslında amel imzaladı ve
matematikte çok iyi olduğumuz zaman
yapamayacağınız tabiatta iletişim
kuramayacağınız hiçbir şey yok
hayvanlarla ilgili
bilgilerle ilgili bir yaprak manası
ucundan kesiyorsunuz alıyorsunuz size
söylüyor diyor ki benim asuta ihtiyacım
var Benim fosfora ihtiyacım var Ve şunu
da söylüyor ne kadara ihtiyacı olduğunu
da söylüyor Aa beni bu bitkilerin şu
kadara ihtiyacı varmış diyor yine dünya
kaynaklarına da israf etmeden ihtiyacı
kadar bir şeyi verebiliyor niye
verebiliyorum Çünkü ben matematiği çok
seviyorum
ve matematiği ve istatistiği çok sevdim
istatistikler sel modellemelerle bir
örnek alın onu genele yayabilmek bugün
belki başarılı bir Çiftçi ile daha az
başarılı bir çiftçinin arasındaki en
önemli fark ikimiz de aynı miktarda
tarlada geziyoruz ikimiz de aynı
miktarda güç sahaf ediyoruz ama benim
tarlama geldiğin zaman
Coşan bir bitki örtüsü onu tarlasına
gittiğiniz zaman
haberi var
ürünle karşılaşıyorsunuz ineklere gelin
aynı şey ineklerle Biz matematikle
iletişim
inekleri işte ayaklarına
çoğumuzda teknolojik saatler var işte
adım sayımızı ölçüyoruz uykumuzun
kalitesini ölçüyoruz ve bunların hepsi
inekler için zaten biz 15 yıldır
yapıyoruz ve biz 15 yıldır bu dataları
toplayıp bu datalarla ineklerle bir
iletişim halindeyiz ve Neye ihtiyaçları
olduğunu bulup sadece ihtiyaçlarıyla
onları
besleyip onlara muazzam bir bakım
sunabiliyor yine matematik sayesinde
yapabiliyoruz
Peki bu kadar şey yaptık
Ne yani Hani bu pala var bu kadar
teknolojiye yatırım yapmışsın Bu sayede
gelip burada hava atıyorsun da
diyebilirim hiç alakası yok Bir sürü
insanın dünyada parası var bu vizyonla
alakalı bir şey
buradayız Vizyon kolejindeyiz hakikaten
tarım ve Vizyon şu anda bütün gençlerin
girdikleri zaman o dal olarak tarıma
girdikleri zaman sıkılma şansları yok
bakın Bugün
yeni bir projeye başladık daha iyi şu
bir ay iki ay önce projede Kanada da var
projede İspanya var projede Bizler varız
biz
karbon salınımının
birisini 3D modelleme ile
ölçüp
resimlendirebileceğiz Yani benim
çiftliğimden ne kadar
salınım yapılıyorsa Biz bunu bir şey
olarak yani görsel olarak
modelleyebileceğiz nasıl kanal olan bir
tane uçak gelecek dronlar gelecek
sensörler o sensörlerle datalar alınacak
ve bu datalarla
işte Mesela Google olarak da gördüğünüz
gibi aynı haritayı Şimdi farklı bir
katman olarak düşünün ne kadar emisyon
olduğunu görebileceksiniz
çiftçilik artık buraya geliyor
çiftçilikte eskisi gibi güç kullanayım
işte
sapağında kürekle bilmem neydi bunların
hiçbir tanesi kalmadı çiftçilikteki
artık tek önemli bir şey üretmek de
değil
ürettiğinizi katma değerli bir şekilde
pazarlamakla Çiftçi değil çok çok önemli
belki ihmal edilen en önemli kısmı yine
biz yolumuzu Biraz geniş tutmanız lazım
bugün
dünyanın en büyük ikinci makarna
üreticisi Türkiye ama makarnada dendiği
zaman hangi ülke akla geliyor
İtalya
aramızdaki Tek fark ne pazarlama biz
belki tarlada iş yapmak istemeyeceksiniz
ama unutmayın gıda Bugün de var yüz yıl
önce de vardı bin yıl önce de vardı bin
yıl sonra da olmaya devam edecek ve
inanın sağlıklı gıda dendiği zaman akla
doğal gıdığa geliyor Dolayısıyla yaratım
ürettiğinin haricindeki hiçbir şeyi
iktisadi
düşünceler haricinde insanlara
tükettiremezsiniz doğal olanı insanlar
tüketmek istiyorlar dolayısıyla her
zaman üretilenin toprakta üretilen ve
doğal şekilde üretilmiş olan bir ürünü
insanlar talep edecekleri için bu
tarafta iyi bir Pazarlama ile Türkiye
Petrol zengini bir ülkeden daha Zengin
olabilir öyle bir coğrafyaya sahibiz ki
bugün bir
Trakya kaşarının eski kaşarının bir
İzmir tulumunun
lezzetine yaklaşabilen ikinci bir
peynirden denk gelmedim İsviçre'de
bitmiş bir insan olarak ama biz bunu
pazarlayabiliyor muyuz Hayır kaç kişi
gidiyor ama gri
olarak bütün dünya artık sana Böyle
orada bir tık geç kaldık farkındaysanız
Türkiye'nin size sunduğu
sınırsız bu alanda imkanlar var yerel ve
yöresel Yeter ki çerçevenin dışına
birazcık çıkmayı Başarır çerçevede şu
oğlum Doktor ol oğlum Avukat ol oğlum
işte bir
baltaya sapan
kötü haberim var size Muhtemelen Bundan
20 saniye sonra çok daha fazla Doktor
üremeyecektir Çünkü
yapay zeka ve robotik gelişimleri artık
doktorların ihtiyaçlarını çok
azaltacaktır şoförlük zaten bitiyor onun
dışında birçok meslek grubu artık
olmayacak ve sizlerin gireceği meslekler
bugün daha çok keşfedilmedi icaz bile
edilmedi Dolayısıyla henüz olmayan bir
meslek demin sohbeti geçiyordu burada
söylemek istiyorum herif Tepesi of
theation silme silme müdürüm
Bugün en büyük sosyal medya
Ağlarını tanıyorsunuz hepsinde bir tane
Help Of ya
silme etik değerler
kanun bunu bilmeniz lazım Burada aynı
zamanda pazarlamayı da bilmeniz lazım
orada olabilmeniz için ve yüzlerce
insanı yönetebiliyor olmanız lazım kim
düşünürler her of the işi diye bir
mesleğin olacağı da ondan 5 sene önce
bunun gibi bir sürü ileriye dönük
potansiyeliniz var Hiçbir şey kapalı
Tutmayın ama ben Bu sektöre sonradan
girdiğim için
önyargılarım olmadığı için o kadar
şanslıyım ki herkesin imkansız değil
veya düşünmediği allah’ın sadece
matematikle
eğitimle eleştirel düşünce kabiliyeti ve
sorgulamayla kimsenin yapmadığı bir
anımsık sistemi kimsenin düşünmediği bir
üretim sistemini devreye soktum ve en
çok karşılaştığım şey ve aslında şu
andaki konuşmanın ana noktasına gelmek
istiyorum
o kadar donanımlı olmanız lazım
yaptığınız şeyin farklı olduğu zaman
bunu sona erdirebilmeniz için kendinize
güveniyor olmanız lazım Bunun için
eğitimini çok iyi aldığınız bir konu
olması lazım bana hep şu söylendi zengin
bebesi geldi
bataklığımın içerisinde hayvanları
öldürecek ve buradan bir gün defolup
gidecek bu çiftlikte burada kalacak Bunu
söyleyenlerin hepsi sektörün duaya
geri tabir ettiğimiz örnek çiftçileriydi
Bugün aynı kişiler benim yaptığım ağır
sistemde yapmaya başladılar ve bunu
yaparken çok büyük zorluklar yaşadı ve
biz sana söylemiştik biz sana
söylemiştik Niye böyle yapıyorsun herkes
gibi niye yapmıyorsun diye o kadar
eleştiri aldın ki o eleştiriyi en zor
günümüzde aldığınız zaman kafanızda en
ufak bir soru işareti oluşmaması için
öncelikle
doğradığımızda aldığımız bir bilginin
doğru olduğundan %100 emin olabiliyor
olmanız gerekiyor
güveniyor olmanız lazım yani güvenilir
kaynaktan bilgi edinmeyin o bilgiyi
edinirken de eleştiren düşünebilmeniz
burada belki temel Ondan sonra ikinci ve
en önemli
ısrarcı olacaksınız dünyada
başarılı iş adamı
bir başarılı sporcu
bir günde başarılı
olmuyor ve inanın düşük kalfalarla dolu
bir serüven vardır benim arkamda
Ben her düşüşünden sonra yılabilirdim
bırakabilirdim inanın burama çok geldi
Lanet olsun deyip bir de böyle çok zor
bir dönemdesiniz işte dakika işte eksi
veriyor yarın çiçekler var Nasıl
öleceğini düşünüyorsun ineklerden 3
tanesi düşmüş Bir tanesinin bebesi arıza
yapmış Tam o arada gübre çukuru taşmış
o arada pompa ters çalışıyor aşağı gübre
ile yıkanıyorsunuz o anda
yılmamak çok önemli eve geliyorsunuz
kızınıza sarılacaksınız of Baba Çok kötü
kokuyorsun
hepsi aynı anda geliyor Bir de biliyor
musunuz ve o aynı anda geldiği zaman
bile en kötü anınızda bile Eğer
hedefinize inanıyorsanız donanımınız
varsa
ve inancınız varsa
yalayacaksınız Çünkü yıllarsanız belki
dünyanın en hızlı koşucusu veya en iyi
bisikletçisi olma yolunda giderken bile
sadece düştüğünüz için bir daha
bisiklete binmezseniz hiçbir zaman dünya
şampiyonu olma şansımız yok ben
dünya rekorunu kıracağım
Yarın birçok işte kıracağım
bir tanesi dünyadaki ilk
net 0 karbon atığı ile üretim yapan
hayvan çiftliği olacak
Allah Allah
hayvanlar metan gazı Çıkartıyor bu adam
sıfır karbondan bahsediyor nasıl olacak
çerçevenin dışına çıkarak ve matematikle
olabiliyor mu hepinize göstereceğim
olduğunu ben dünyada en yüksek verimi
alan ama bunu da ene ekonomik koşullarda
alan üretici olacağım niye biliyor
musunuz birisi yapmış mı Benim hiçbir
eksim yok orada
Benim de her şey var Sadece yapmaya
kalmış ama bu arada düşeceğim de geçen
sene
hayatımda yaşadığım en kötü üretim
sezonunu yaşadım Hala da
sulamayla ilgili problem olduğu verimler
yerlerin olduğu Ben geçen seneden çok
daha hırslıyım bugün başarmak için Çünkü
inanıyorum ve Biliyorum ve hedefim
herkesin yaptığının dışında bir şeyi
Türkiye topraklarında ve bir Türk
üreticisi olarak yapmak istiyorum orada
da birazcık milliyetçi tarafım var Orada
belki bir zaafım olabilir Onu zaaf
olarak tanımlayabilirsiniz Ama bunu da
başaracağım dünyanın en ekonomik en
verimli İşletmesi olacak
herkese rağmen olacağım herkesin
yapamazsın demesine rağmen olacağım
neyle olacak
matematikle olacak
bol bol okuyarak olacağım eleştirel soru
sorarak doğru insanlardan bilgi alarak
olacak
Bugün size vermek istediğim en önemli
mesaj özellikle gençlerin lütfen ne
kadar kötü giderse gitsin hayatımızda ne
kadar şey aynı anda pens giderse gitsin
bilin ki o gün sizin büyüyeceğiniz gün o
gün sizin işte başarıya ulaşacağınız
günde olacaktır lütfen yalvarmayın Çok
teşekkür ediyorum
[Alkış]